I was I was I was a terrible person to
work with really that's why I can't
manage like I've not got the patience
and I expect everyone to do it the way
that I do it reality is they're not
right no one's the same that's a sink in
real quick you know I had a pretty good
job prior to working in recruitment I
was a supervisor of a restaurant and I
earned really good money and that's how
I learned to talk to people and have no
judgment on where you come from because
I had the same conversation with them as
I would with someone that's just coming
for a bowl of chips and a glass of Rosie
no judgment here like we all love it I
think that when I started making good
money again but it was probably four
times the amount of money that I'd made
doing that other job I was like oh my
God I'm Beyonce like I just all of a
sudden got in my head and thought I was
this person that I wasn't